sharing the great irony of this would be
if he's not tradable because these civil
lawsuits 22 now and possibly more have
been filed and are moving through the
court system it's possible that the nfl
would eventually put him on the
commissioner exempt list i wrote this
today and i said it last week don't be
shocked if he shows up if he scraps the
plan to not report because if he does
report and gets put on the commissioner
exemplist he gets paid in full for 2021
and loses no money and doesn't have to
play this is his way of not playing for
the texans and still getting paid and
i'm sure that the texans will regard
that as an unfair outcome but
that's how the paid leave procedures
work i don't like the paid leave
procedures i don't think it's good for
anybody it just allows the nfl to not
have players who are facing charges that
have not yet been resolved on tv screens
and us in a position where we have to
talk about them during games after games
before games throughout the season it's
a way to take the heat out of a hot
kitchen but it's also a way for deshaun
watson to get paid at a time when he
otherwise was not going to show up for
the houston texans this year shireen
that could be where this is heading
gosh mike you think about the timeline
with deshaun watson i mean think back to
september when he signs the huge
contract right he leads the league in
passing but the texans are terrible he
comes out the day after the season or
right after the the last game uh and
criticizes you know the the entire
texans organization and says here's what
we need and then all of a sudden he
asked for a trade and now here we are
with him being untradeable i you don't
you just can't fathom
really what's happened over the last few
months i mean it's not even been a year
to go from being a well-paid star of a
team that thinks they're going to have
him forever and he's going to lead him
to multiple championships
now
basically untradeable and the team
doesn't want you either what it where
does your future land and and no one
knows that right now you talk about not
knowing what somebody's future is i
think it's absolutely no one knows right
now what deshawn watson's future is
yeah absolutely and
miles simmons and i talked about this
last week and i'm just going to
summarize this briefly for anyone who
missed it i want to write something
about it at pft as to how these
processes will play out with 22 lawsuits
but
assuming that they do
one trial ultimately potentially for
each lawsuit it's possible some would be
resolved others will go forward who
knows you've got 22 different
individuals who have their own rights
and their own decisions that they can
make as to how they go about
moving forward
with
these cases and these claims
you could have in theory 22 trials and
when you consider the lower standard of
proof the he said she said nature of
these allegations
if you have 22 trials shireen this is
the equivalent of 22 coin flips all
coming up your way that's how much of a
crapshoot taking a case to trial is the
judge the jury so many factors that come
into it so much uncertainty the chances
of winning every single one of those for
desean watson are very very very small
as long as you have basic testimony that
doesn't get thrown out of court that
gets put in front of a jury you never
know which jury is going to respond well
to deshaun watson and which one won't
that's what he's facing if he doesn't
find a way to make this situation right
with a settlement of as many of these
claims as possible if not all of them
and his career potentially is going to
be put on hold until these cases are
resolved which could take up to really
18 months to two years
yeah and i was going to ask mike how
long this potentially could take because
we know nothing moves fast through the
court system so wouldn't it be
beneficial to him to make these things
go away to settle all 22 of these cases
um it's look
this is going to take a while and the
question becomes
what will the nfl do if there's not
criminal charges
but if there are civil charges if there
are this many antonio brown's
playing played last year plenty of guys
play with civil lawsuits pending but
with 22 of them
what will the nfl do and if any traction
happens with these criminal cases
that's the kind of thing that could mean
that desean watson doesn't play again at
all until this all gets resolved so
we'll see how it all plays out hi i'm
mike tarico and thanks for watching make
sure to hit subscribe for the latest
news and highlights from nbc sports